ce sont les nouvelles images satellites
qui atteste du renforcement de la
présence militaire russe à ses
frontières avec l'ukraine d'après maksar
technologies le groupe qui à capter et
analyser ces photos on y voit des
centaines de blindés et stationnaires
parfois quelques kilomètres seulement de
la frontière avec l'ukraine comme en
russie en crimée où ici en biélorussie
voisine ces deux dernières semaines se
sont érigés des tentes et des abris
preuve que le déploiement humains
s'intensifierait selon l'otan près de
cent mille soldats russes sont déployés
depuis plusieurs mois à la frontière
ukrainienne
je vais pas vous cacher la situation est
très grave tous les éléments sont réunis
pour qu'il y ait une intervention le
constat c'est massification des forces
des temps que des plans d'aidé soutien
aux fourneaux aux militaires aux
frontières le risque majeur qui est là
mais en même temps il y a la volonté de
dialoguer les russes ne sont pas les
seuls à procéder à un redéploiement
militaire sur ordre du président byden
des soldats américains vont être
déployés en roumanie en pologne et en
allemagne certains étaient déjà sur le
territoire européen d'autres seront
envoyées directement des états unis un
message fort envoyé la russie même si le
pentagone temporise
je veux être très clair là dessus ce ne
sont pas des redéploiements permanent
ils sont déplacés pour répondre à
l'environnement sécurité actuelles
de plus ces forces ne vont pas se battre
en ukraine elles vont assurer la défense
robuste de nos alliés de l'otan
900 soldats américains étaient déjà
présents roumanie leur nombre va plus
que doubler en pologne ils passeront de
4000 à
5701 groupe aéronaval est actuellement
maire adriatique et se dit prêt à être
repositionnés à tout moment moscou
dénonce des manoeuvres qui réduisent le
champ pour les décisions politiques